hi welcome back to another gadget lab
show I'm Michael Cole Ori Nam Nathan Lee
about his Giles coming up in a little
bit we're gonna take a look at the new
subwoofer from Sonos the wireless
speaker company but first naked has a
phone the Motorola Atrix HD what tell us
all about it well it's actually really
awesome and I'll tell you why for one
thing it's running a high scream
sandwich Android 4.0 and I used to like
HT HT C's version of Ice Cream Sandwich
the best but this version is even better
because it is really stripped down it's
almost close to stock Android Wow which
is if they ditch their what are they
using motoblur yeah modems motoblur is
gone you still do have this social media
widget which takes some of your contacts
I guess people you contact a lot and
kind of puts their faces up here but you
know it's really stripped down it's
really fast it looks good it works good
the widgets that they do have are
helpful in the past it just felt bloated
and slow and it wasn't a good experience
good UI now I remember the thing about
the Atrix when it first came out it was
the first Motorola phone that had like
the whole sort of accessories yeah it
goes system around yeah web tops then
they had lap docks and yeah so it was if
you don't remember
14 15 months ago when the first Atrix
came out it was a phone that you plugged
into the back of this sort of dumb
laptop and the film became the brains
for the laptop yeah powered well yeah it
was just kind of weird and it was really
expensive it was like several hundred
dollars yeah and you could also buy like
a funky dock for you know connecting it
to your HDMI all that work on your HDTV
all that's gone oh that's gone now
there's an HDMI port in the top and kind
o more webtop no no that's happening
okay it's good because it was nonsense
it's good what do you have you do have a
four and a half inch screen here with a
1280 by 720 resolution okay so is it a
good screen beautiful it's beautiful
it's not too big no no I mean you know
four and a half inches I think is a
decent size it's on the big side of
things but it's not too big so your
hands thanks
I think it looks really good the colors
are a little oversaturated but it's a
beautiful display the the pixel density
rivals the HTC One X and the iPhone 4
and 4s okay and gorgeous the two phones
you just mentioned are like the the top
of the heap and when it comes to it yeah
how does this one rank you know this one
Falls just a bit below it's just a
little thicker but it's fantastic it's
still fast it's only a hundred bucks on
a two-year contract so it's actually a
little bit less expensive than the 4s oh
and the 1x but it's it's a screamer it's
actually you know a relative deal and my
what about what about battery life
battery life isn't the greatest it's
kind of on par with what we saw with the
Droid Razr you're definitely kind of
looks like yeah it looks a lot like the
razor you still have the kevlar back you
know back here it's thin this little
camera bump but it actually has about
half the battery life that you saw maybe
the razor max which would last a day day
and a half sometimes two days to Pam I
use it this one you're gonna want to
carry your charger with you you can go
pretty quick its 4G LTE you got a big
screen yeah that are just gonna get
drained like mad yep yeah other than
that though cool phone loving it it's
great alright enough about that let's
talk about the subwoofer
so check this thing out this is a
subwoofer it's called the sub
it's from Sonos the wireless speaker
company it has this sort of hole in the
middle this sort of doughnut design it's
very attractive yeah but it is kind of
bulky it's about 16 inches squared and
about 6 inches deep so it's also
designed so you can lay it flat and
slide it under a couch or something like
that any of your desk yeah so yeah it's
a wireless it's a wireless speaker it's
a wireless subwoofer and it looks good
so but does it operate on its own or do
you have to have because I mean
sometimes they make a bunch of stuff
right so you have to be like a Sonos
person basically right you have to be
one of those people who has so no stuff
in their home in order for this to make
sense so if you have one of these which
is the the play 3 speaker ok to make one
that's a little bit bigger called the
play 5 there's one that's even a little
bit bigger
they make amps that you can hook up to
your existing sound system but you know
it's all Wireless and everything's
controlled through your smartphone you
add this and it takes over all the
low-end so basically everything that is
below about 90 Hertz or so nice the sub
frequencies so good bass yeah and that's
actually I mean you know that's what a
subwoofer supposed to do but for Sonos
it's pretty cool because like these
speakers they're kind of small they
don't really represent the low-end that
well like they're pretty good but when
you add this to the equation you get
like that big beefy low-end that you
would get out of a really nice big you
know 3 4 speaker system yeah I heard you
testing it out earlier today it sounded
fantastic
yeah really kicks my favorite thing
about it is that if it's not kicking
quite enough or if you don't like the
results are getting you could adjust
everything just using the app on your
phone so you can crank it up you can
change the tonal quality of it you can
turn it way down like you listen to
something with a ton of bass in it's
just too overwhelming you can ease it
back and it's just you know a couple of
taps and you change the whole color of
it does it work with maybe a Jawbone
Jambox or if I have some you know wired
you know bookcase speakers it's like
can I can i mix it up or is this only
really a Sonos product for it it's only
Sonos okay so you have to you have to be
invested in the Sonos ecosystem for this
to make sense for you
speaking of investment how much does
think of $700 kind of a lot of money it
is now like some of the stuff has never
been cheap it's always been a little bit
too expensive but you know you're not
just paying for sound cuz you can get a
simple for half the money that sounds as
good as this one it says two drivers
it's ported it's really intelligently
designed speaker but you know there's a
lot of really intelligently designed
speakers out there so the only reason
you're buying this is because it fits
into the whole wireless home multi-room
audio system that you've already
invested a couple of grand into or you
know five six hundred dollars into by
being associate for the convenience the
overall user experience yeah which is
awesome by the way yeah I must say like
you know I've tested airplay stuff and
DLNA stuff and you know Bluetooth stuff
you mentioned like the jam box and this
is so ridiculously easy to set up yeah
you like plugged in you press the button
you bring up the iPhone app and then in
about 30 seconds all of a sudden you got
base alright it was I was really
surprised I was like that's it yeah so
that's that's why you that's why you
paid a premium all right so much stuff
but it's pretty awesome to look at too
so if you're a big fan of design you
know stylish it is stylish yeah what do
you think I think it looks good I think
that I'd like to listen to it a little
bit more 700 bucks it's a lot you know
but like you said if you're already
invested in that it might be worth it
yeah and you know if it's for you or not
just by the word Sonos you know whether
or not this is something you're going to
buy anyway that's all we have time for
this week and we'll see you next time